so what we do is you know you you want
to create a campaign let's say for the
year where you say we want to focus on
three or four
core messages like you can't force
people
to consume more than that
um and then we combine that with
frequent and randomized phishing
simulations and
those are like fake phishing emails that
you used to to test are people falling
for it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with leumitech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford leap and
in media partnership with c-tech
hello hello welcome to another episode
of 20-minute leaders today we're going
to be talking about cyber security but
from the lenses of a content creator and
cyber security awareness
meet anna collard svp of content
strategy and evangelist of know before
africa
anna is currently svp of content
strategy and evangelist for know before
africa where she drives a security
awareness across the african continent
collard founded security content
publisher popcorn training now part of
no before which is a south african
company that promotes cyber security
awareness by using innovative story
based techniques and gamification to
make complex content simple to
understand and easy to remember welcome
anna anna collard welcome to 20 minute
leaders svp of content strategy and
evangelist for know before africa how
are you
thank you so much yeah it's great to be
here thanks i'm well
thank you for for joining me from south
africa and
talking about cyber security content i i
know the world of cyber security from
the zeros and ones perspective not so
much from the awareness perspective
you're the winner of multiple awards and
recognized globally as a cyber security
leader and you've been mentioned quite a
few times i believe in the top 50 women
in cyber security in africa my few
magazines so so it's a huge privilege to
talk to you today about about your work
and your understanding about you know
what does it mean to
storytelling with cyber security but
especially in the context of of africa
so anna walk me through a little bit
both a little bit about you about your
own journey getting to this conviction
that this is what you want to do but
also what does it mean to be a
storyteller and content creation in the
world of cyber security
yeah i think that i'll have to actually
take you back quite a long time because
um when i was a kid um i always used to
to draw cartoons like that was my thing
like i made these little cartoon stories
and
when i wanted to study i said i want to
do art and my dad was like nah there's
no money in it you know so i had to do
um and then i wanted to do languages
he's like no there's no money so i ended
up doing international economics
and part of the
that cause it was like a three-year ba
equivalent was to um
do an internship um you know in in
different countries i went to singapore
and south africa that's how i ended up
here
but um
like
the the cyber security side of it also
came more as an accident like i i was a
student and um you know like as all
students you sort of make money on the
side through waitressing and then i had
this opportunity to work for siemens
which is like a
a germany-based um large international
i.t company and they
had like a thing called siemens student
program so i ended up working there and
that paid better than waitressing and
that's how i got into cyber security and
i ended up writing my thesis and
security but from a business point of
view
and that that little piece of work got
me into security um
full time and the first 10 years i think
i just spent
um you know sort of trying to keep up
with all my engineering
colleagues because i didn't have a tech
background i came from the economic side
and but i did a lot of sort of
certifications on the side
um and i i worked for a big network
integrator sort of as the interface
between product development managed
services and and sales so i was sort of
interpreter between the tech and the
business side
and i enjoyed that i think
i have a feeling that the the idea of
interpretation is going to come up often
in this conversation yeah
and
i think like i love learning you know in
general like i just enjoy learning new
things and cyber security is one of that
field where you have to learn new things
every day
and um but because i was quite sort of
in that more in a technical architecture
side of things and doing
um you know audits and assessments as
well as
i mean and
we call it architecture design where you
go into a big corporate and then you
define where
there's security controls need to go in
that was sort of my my job at the end
but
um
on the side like in fact during my
honeymoon i drew this whole cartoon
story
um of
like sort of security principles for
non-technical people and
um i took those drawings back home and i
showed it to this customer that was that
was based on site old mutual as one of
south africa's biggest insurance
companies
and um i just showed it to them like as
a joke you know and they said no this is
great and like you should do this and
then
um i found these like animators who
are incredible like they did work for
like disney and
and um
i mean first i tried my own animation
and it's really hard work so like i
found them and um they've they're still
i mean this is this was 10 years ago so
2011. they're still with us today and we
just sort of met in a coffee shop and i
said to them look there's a story and
how can i make this into into
like a little movie clip
and then through
this this customer who said they wanted
it you know we also had to develop like
a learning management system
and they sort of the customer really
pushed me into taking this little side
project that i had just in my mind you
know the story that i drew on honeymoon
and then that eventually became a
business because
sort of i built it with the customer's
inputs we built the system with the
customer's input i did make sure that
the ip remained mine so i could take it
to other clients who i've met over the
years you know working as a security
consultant and um it's sort of what like
um
what's it word of mouth sort of you know
like
they took my stories and then
um it went into all the
bigger south african enterprise
customers like um
telcom and the banks and you know and it
was still only a side project it was
only two years later that i sort of
registered it as a full full-blown
business and i went full-time
and then a few years after that we
managed to get onto gartner's magic
quadrant which was also quite a big deal
and then yeah number four got wind of of
us and they acquired us three years ago
and um
yeah
you know
sorry
the world of content and cyber security
and especially in africa first of all
what it what is no know before africa
and how does content and storytelling
and security play into this organization
yeah so my company was called popcorn
training and we created um
basically
stories to explain to non-technical
people how to
you know like not fall for phishing
emails um
by the way what did you learn from that
what what was what is it what are some
tips for
com for discussing technical issues with
non-technical people
the fact that it's actually it has
nothing to do with technology it's all
about if we talk about social
engineering which is really one of the
biggest threats in the cyber security
space would you know at least like
affecting humans they use psychology to
trick us and one of the things that i
always teach people is you know um at
the end of the day it it's all about um
using your critical thinking like your
prefrontal cortex and not full sort of
victim to your own emotions and that's
all they do is like they send you
something that either sounds really
great or it causes like a low grade form
of fear and as soon as those you know
amygdala nerve centers trigger you don't
think critically anymore and you're more
likely to you know open that attachment
or hand over information and really good
social engineers that's what they do is
they try and get you to hijack your
critical thinking so at the end of the
day it's actually about being mindful
taking a breather and thinking before
you do anything before you react to
anything incoming before you hand over
anything that's you know over the phone
for example because it's another good
way of doing social engineering and and
unfortunately not to trust your emotions
you know like to be more
well righteous
what is the mo what was the most
efficient form of communicating this
information is it is it written video
drawings
uh face to face
so it really depends also on the
audience and we obviously
built a lot of stories into videos just
because it's more
um it's the easiest way of communicating
nowadays and this was even before you
know i mean this is like i said 10 years
ago before the sort of youtube and um
that kind of i mean there was youtube
around obviously but it wasn't as big
then but i think nowadays even more so
you have to make it really short and
attention span has obviously you know
gone down so if you have a message you
need to
bring that across within a minute if you
can
um
and sort of really succinct but at the
same time you need to engage people's
emotions so that they pay attention
that they're interested in it and so it
is quite it's more of a psychological
game really um and you and you have to
use marketing and communication
techniques to get people to
want to listen i mean if you just send
out like some random i.t
security policy message everyone is like
of course you know yeah
so it is more important to make it
personally relevant make it a bit fun if
you can
use humor your story um techniques
all of that
is sort of you know more effective than
your
right
now what do you have to do as sort of
the interpreter
in this situation
to both understand the material but then
to be able to convey it in a way that is
i guess either not not entertaining but
is at least interesting enough for other
people to to really think through it and
then because you're also asking them to
adopt a certain behavior afterwards so
it's not just it doesn't just end there
right
exactly and i think that's that's that's
a good point you know at the end of the
day we wanting to change behavior so
awareness is sort of the first step like
you need to get people from ignorance to
okay i get that now but how do we get
them to actually change their behavior
that's a whole different ballgame but at
the interpretation part um i think one
thing that i use a lot of is analogies
sort of all metaphors you know to take
something
technical but then create a sort of real
life story around it to explain those
concepts in a simple way because so many
people even though we like
you know everything is digitized but
there are a lot of people that still
don't understand a lot of the basics or
they don't want to understand like for
example
how to um
like the way a url is constructed you
know like people really don't know that
even though you think it's it's so
simple but you can't just tell people ah
don't you know you need to figure out
how to spot this this phishing link if
they don't know what a legitimate link
should look like they have to like then
use analogies and
uh created this whole analogy of
thinking of it like a address you know
and then you have the
1.00 as like your country and then you
know you have to like really build it up
as like a lucky would explain it to your
grandmother for example but do it in an
obviously a non-patronizing way and in a
fun way if possible so that
even the most non-technical person will
get it
and how do you measure yourself whether
you're successful because i guess one of
the most difficult challenges here is
you don't really know whether they
understood it whether they enjoyed it
whether they're implementing it later
right
well there i mean the number four um you
know the company who bought us today
obviously sort of the leaders in the
security cult we could actually call it
security culture space
and their platform is quite powerful and
that a the the users can raise the
content so you get direct feedback from
the users with you know the stars or
like sort of thumbs up and and comments
as well
and and then what we do is and this is
what talks to that whole behavior side
is we don't just
use content by itself like you have to
combine the content with simulation
techniques such as phishing simulations
so what we do is you know you you want
to create a campaign let's say for the
year where you say we want to focus on
three or four
core messages like you can't force
people
to consume more than that
um and then we combine that with
frequent and randomized phishing
simulations and
those are like fake phishing emails yeah
that you used to to test are people
falling for it but also it's sort of on
the job training because even the most
sort of skeptical person they're often
actually in the i.t department's like i
won't fall for that if they do fall for
it it's the best type of learning right
because then they they like get the
whole oops you know
um kind of thing and
they then we can also teach them the red
flags and that's one metric you can use
to measure sort of behavior but then we
also do something called the security
culture assessment where we actually go
in
and scientifically test those and
there's seven dimensions that that make
up a security culture that ranges from
people's attitudes to their level of
knowledge to the way they feel that
they're accountable or not accountable
for security and that can be done on an
annual basis as well to see well how do
i actually
you know i've compared
to how i was last year and also how do i
compare against industry benchmarks
where is it really bad like if the
attitude for example is really bad then
you should try and do something to
change that right get people to be more
positive
um so that's another good way of
doing it because at the end of the day
you can't manage something if you can't
measure it
so how many years would you say you're
and you're an interpreter by profession
a little bit yeah
yeah i think i've i've been there my
whole year like even as an entrepreneur
at the end of the day you have to take a
lot of stuff that's complicated and then
you simplify to down what actually
matters right
that goes a long way but do you feel
that you know in the world of cyber
security has it been
getting easier or harder to
to do this job to to navigate through
the content and through the
the different challenges in a way that
non-technical people will understand
that's a good question i think it has
become easier in some way because it's
it's so i mean when i first started in
cyber security it was such a niche area
you know right
and now everybody is sort of in stuff
it's it's massive like it's a really big
industry so more and there's also more
common
um sort of
public mainstream media awareness and
knowledge especially now and i mean with
the latest um breaches and ransomware
attacks that really make it into
front-page media you know sort of i
think it it
like people have a better understanding
of it in general so it makes it easier
but then the complete the complication
comes in
um
when you then really go down into the
nitty-gritties uh
you know because now
and then you know like even though i i
said in the beginning it's about
thinking and sort of not falling for
social engineering attacks there are a
couple of other basic controls that um
everybody should do like using
multi-factor authentication for example
um
but
yeah i think it it does get
as we as we use more technology and it's
sort of all over our lives um you have
to be more aware of it and there's more
to think about so i think it has become
more complex
so i'm hearing you say that there's an
interesting balance that on one hand is
becoming easier in the sense of people
are starting to understand the jargon
they're understanding the the importance
of it and so there's this there's some
language that there's some foundation to
work on at the same time we're going
deeper into the possibilities things are
becoming things are becoming trickier
and more complicated and therefore the
content itself may be a little bit a
little bit more convolutive and so um i
don't even think that convolution is a
word maybe it's convolutive
i want i really want to thank you for
for these 20 minutes they're really
really great and and i have a few more
questions about you not about uh cyber
security or content i want to take you
back to your childhood what really
fascinated you as a kid before you
discovered cyber security
art i love drawing
and and painting
do that on the side i love doing that
with my kids and i think that was
something that um i did i'm an introvert
you know so you can put me in a room
with some i don't know something to draw
on and that keeps me happy
um so that yeah
and what inspires you today
africa does i think you know like africa
is such an amazing continent we have
like the youngest population at the
average age here is 19. um there is a
lot of sort of misconception that it's
just third world it's not like we
definitely have different levels of
wealth and sort of economic opportunity
and um yeah i think
it's the right place to be
i love it and so when you're doing your
your work within africa i guess right
most of the work is within africa yeah
right now yeah
do you anticipate that the work that
you're doing within africa for know
before is that is that a different type
of work than you would necessarily do
let's say for for the united states or
for europe
i think i mean we have we have to try
and keep
um consensus
relevant so
right originally
yeah so we try and use local accents
funny enough though is that sometimes um
the south african accents are the
americans like it so we
so even the sense of humor which i
thought oh you know
it's a bit cheesy but they they seem to
like it so
um yeah it translates quite well across
the pond even
very very cool and last question what
are three words you would use to
describe yourself
um
i
try to be present
i mean i try it really is so i'm huge
into yoga that's one of the things
i try to be creative and have fun
i love it anna thank you very very much
and thank you for the great work you're
doing and disseminating this information
making it accessible it's so important
i'm personally a little bit terrified
about where we're going with cyber
security and and you know we need people
to be informed and and a lot a lot of
the times the foundations and what i'm
hearing from you the foundations that
you're setting with people they can
really save organizations and those
organizations at the end help save us so
thank you anna for everything and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you michaels
it's great talking to you
you